joining us right now on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line here on
the rich eisen show prior to his fifth
year
in the national football league courtesy
of our friends at snickers juju smith
schuster how are you juju
i'm doing today how are you i can't
believe it you're this your fifth year
it was it was
2017 when you came in with your bicycle
and took over pittsburgh literally is
that how long
yeah it's been it's been five years man
going to my fifth year uh and time time
goes by so fast yeah i can't believe it
like a blink of an eye where is that
bicycle you still have the bike juju
from your rookie year yeah yeah yeah of
course of course i like your fans people
are still trying to steal it i got it
locked up storage
what do you mean people are trying to
take it what about your bike really
there's a bike the famous bike because
of the situation that's right okay so
you
you don't bike around pittsburgh anymore
do you
or you do uh i do i do i do uh if it's
nice outside out i'll bike around but i
have multiple bikes instead of incident
yes you're you're in your fifth year
juju come on now okay you got you got
time for more bikes i
i just can't believe it tom how are you
a different receiver now than when you
first
showed up out of uh usc juju smith
schuster oh man uh honestly mentally i
became mentally stronger uh being able
to
uh look at defense differently
at first you know i used to go into the
game and just play ball and off to
knowledge i just know but over the past
years of being able to you know
nice like a deacon study
uh uh individual players and stuff like
that over time going against them
uh you know i've grown uh mentally and
i'll say above the uh above the
shoulders
above the shoulders knowing you know
where to be your routes and things like
that that's what you're referring to
yes yes yes did you see the comment by
brady that went all over the place on
twitter and instagram and everything
else about
how you shouldn't depend on defensive
players to protect you and the league is
flagging them
for hitting receivers where receivers
shouldn't be because they don't know not
to be there they should know better with
film study and quarterback should know
not to lead them into that spot did you
see
all of that
juju did they yeah yeah i saw that what
did you think of it as a receiver in the
nfl what do you think of that uh man
would you say over the time a period of
just football of the nfl that you know
it's becoming uh something where you
know it's more often cited uh just
because they want to see more often
score you know obviously
uh it's more so it's slighted to the
opposite side like i said quarterbacks
are being fixed being saved uh multiple
times you know uh just because
uh you know the nfl wants to see offense
score they want to see points on the
board they want to see excitement they
want to see
uh uh
the game you know
go on it keeps the people interested you
know uh i think it's more so
for sales in that sense um as a receiver
i think they're protecting us i think
over the time you know you got guys like
you know trophy marvel had read guys who
were just you know smashing out left and
right but now it's like if you get hit a
certain way oh you're penalized and
could possibly be kicked out of the game
and possibly get kicked out for two
following games so this is all the time
well you've been you've been you've been
flagged right for for hitting people
you've been flagged for that sort of
thing yeah of course of course i
remember that that whole moment where
where you were uh it's seemingly you
know uh striking a blow on behalf of all
steeler nation against a bengal that has
uh
taken taken people out um throughout the
years um so the only reason why i'm
bringing this up again is just i guess
it kind of dovetails in not only with
what you're here to talk about with
snickers but what brady said too is just
knowing
knowing the game that receivers should
know where to be
schematically and if they don't they
might stroll into a spot where they
should know better because the defense
has already not only shown itself on
film but clearly pre-snap before the
the moment where you're strolling into a
spot where you're getting blown up you
know what i mean
yeah yeah yeah and that's his
preparation you know running your route
uh throughout the week and you know
preparing for that game but then again
you know there's times where you know
you scramble and you you go into a spot
where you don't know you don't see that
guy and like you said you know the
quarterback has to know that hey don't
throw that because you know
that person might be there that person
is coming downhill
but at the end of the day like i said if
it's just football you know i know
myself was you know just going out there
play and uh all these new rules i get it
it protects us and it is protecting the
game protecting the quarterbacks um but
i think when you had guys i mean you're
paying uh top-notch quarterbacks a lot
of money uh to play throughout the
season you know people want to see that
so they're protecting them and
if that's like their way of the rules
and we just gotta play right because you
know they're making it juju smith
schuster here on the rich eisen show um
why'd you stay in pittsburgh
why'd you stay put
this off season oh
playing with you know big ben obviously
being able to you know i know i know my
head coach they know me they know my
body uh they know what i'm dealing with
and also just
you know having to play my receiver of
having my receiver coaching game and it
just makes life a lot easier you know um
staying with the team where you know
they they utilize you they know you and
being able to put the members i want to
put up the shoes you know as it's
important to me well when you say that
you know you know your coach your coach
knows you tell me about tomlin your
relationship with him
what you uh and and the player that you
are now entering your fifth year how
he's had a role in that
juju
yeah i mean he has a huge role uh i
remember you know
like it was yesterday where you know
walking to the meeting is that name you
just young as johnny's my kids all right
you know i can babysit you
that's what he said and now to the point
not to the point where now we know we're
talking about grown men and how the
family house everything
uh well what's new what's fun and it's
just for me it's like you know our
relationship has always been you know
like a like a brother relationship you
know i got like a big uh
older brother that i can talk to about
anything you know because that's been a
day man we're grown men who are on the
field and we're playing a sport that you
know has a lot of good guys around me
and you know coming in at 20 years old
you know he's kind of thinking under his
wing and pretty much
made me who i am today
so you you consider him a big brother
your coach that's what you you would
term your relationship with tomlin
yeah he's definitely a players coach a
guy that i can see that i can go to and
talk about anything you know outside of
football like not football related and
you know he's been there and helped me
along the way would you mind giving me
an example like what what what outside
of football
way has he shown you the way or you
asked him about
that you'd be willing to share with us i
think i think one of the biggest things
that you know a lot of things that
people deal with is uh
you know i would say that like outside
of like you know being able to
try to make everyone can't make everyone
happy you can't you not being able to
please everyone he told me like hey just
you know make sure that you are good
first before you help others because if
you're not good
then you won't be able to provide what
you want to provide and also many people
have played you know uh what that may be
and whatever they may need
in that sense and uh making sure they're
like hey everybody take care of yourself
and once you do that then you can help
out those around me and you know there's
a lot of other things i can't get into
details but uh definitely a guy that i
you know i can go to uh for anything and
so
let's talk about your offense here juju
smith shuster ben looks spry to me
he looks like he's lighter
big ben lighter would you agree with
that coming into
this year is he different do you look
different to you
yeah i mean this year me uh it's just i
practice you know he's a lot of cardio
you know even
um when we're not uh
we're not up and it's the defense is
practicing and we're you know we're on
the sideline waiting uh ben's on the
sideline you know running doing a lot of
cardio and you know
that's something that he's
that he's been doing but doing it more
often than i've seen
and i noticed that and i can see that
you know him
running you know scrambling making plays
like that's something that's like okay
like
he's right for this reason so when he's
not on the field with you guys
doing drills he's off on the side
running wind sprints and stuff like
doing cardio in a way that he's never
done before
what you're saying uh uh
he's done it before but now he's
actually done and he's doing it more now
that i've noticed and uh i'll say that
like he's getting into more shape okay
and uh have you what's a workout like
with him uh in the off season like a
camp big ben getting you guys all
together what's that one like
ah it's just normal it's just honestly
it's just normal football i mean we go
to the place you know we go through um
we're gonna run this week and
uh during camp it's like you know we
just work on what we need to work on um
not necessarily like uh
lift with him or anything like that but
on the field stuff okay um now
how good is naji harris gonna be
how good can he be i think he's gonna be
really good i mean
i think a lot of people are picking him
up in the fantasy draft oh yes uh but i
could see for myself in person like he's
a legit player
okay like
does he have who does he remind you of
who's who what type of skills does he
have that you look at him
man i i i mean for me overall i think
he's
i think he's his own self
i got a 230 plus you know in the
backfield running uh and having great
hands uh i think he'll be
uh
great for our team i think that i've
noticed too is that he gave it to line
up as a slot receiver and actually you
know run around to make plays uh in the
slot and out of the back though so it's
actually very interesting to see how
he's gonna do [ __ ] obviously with our
new online and everything but
i'm super excited i can't wait to see
him actually ball and i should put on
you know playing the actual games uh
this week so he's bigger than lev bell
right
he's bigger than him oh definitely
wow
definitely bigger
and he's coming out of the backfield
kind of like lev too right like he's
he's a little bit of both
right running outside i would say i
would say a little bit more more so
downhill uh i think red bell is uh hey
like kind of like
pops around a little bit kind of finds
his whole
and strikes i think
he's more like you know he'll find a
hole maybe hop around a little bit but
really likes to run downhill like strike
the field so uh that's a guy who can uh
do a little bit of both but definitely
running down here first okay let's talk
about your program with snickers you're
perfect for this
i mean not only do you know how to talk
and you can
tell stories but i mean uh you were 20
when you came in the league
so this is about rookie mistake of the
year program fans during the nfl season
share examples of their rookie mistakes
they've made
and at the end of the season a rookie
mistake will be crowned this knickers
rookie mistake of the year right that's
the way this is working
juju yeah yeah yeah so uh for entry
snickers uh rookie mistake of the year
you do not it does not have to be floor
related people think that it's all too
well related but it can be fans can
submit the videos image and text of the
rookie mistake for a chance to win uh
for example uh me leaving my dinner at
the stadium out to the game and going
home and not having fun to eat after the
game that's a jerking mistake uh
but like i said you can submit a rich
mistake and learn more fans can head to
snickers rickymistake.com and to follow
along social by using hashtag snickers
roofing mistakes all the fans out there
good luck and you're giving two super
bowl tickets in los angeles they're
right you could see the steelers play
who right
were they playing yeah you see this
dilutes by uh
yeah
i know i mean there's so many great
teams over there well i don't know
no my my social media grand maester tj
jefferson who were they playing the
cowboys okay my bad sorry he's a big
cowboy fan you'll have to excuse him
you're like excuse me
that's his rookie mistake so let me uh
how dare you let me
[Laughter]
so what was your rookie mistake again
give me that one again what what
happened for you
uh my ricky mistake is that we get
dinner after the game i always forget
because i do interviews after the game
so i was fixing my dinner i leave my
dinner in my locker room i supposed to
come back and get it
and i end up just going home and
forgetting about like my dinner
afternoon so now it's late at night i
don't have dinner and gotta find
something to eat
so and then and then you didn't like you
you didn't lock your bike up and things
could just totally
spin out of control right there do you
want to hear what my rookie mistake was
the first first day on the job is in
television i'll tell it to you real
quick this is a good one juju okay okay
so i drove a hat i was in reading
california so you know 12 hours north of
where you went to uh college
and so um so
way north it's like closer to oregon
than than san francisco so
everything's about a half an hour away
from each other so i drove i was in
reading california and i drove a half an
hour away to a town called cottonwood
where i was going to shoot uh some video
of a high school football playoff game
and then in between the two games i
would do a live stand-up you know and
then i would go back and shoot the
second game and so it was time to shoot
the shoot the stand up and i went back
to my car
that uh i drove out there with and uh
needed a battery for the recording
machine that i had
and thought maybe i should take another
tape while i did it too and then i
closed the trunk and then i'm like oh my
god i locked the keys in the trunk of
the car
wait a minute gets worse gets worse i
you know people i was trying to like
jimmy it open it was terrible so very
sweet people
saw the new guy struggling like sweating
there's a hundred degrees out i'm in my
sport coach trying to look good for my
live shot
and they were trying to help the you
know
jack the car open but couldn't and i'm
like just i i just need to go grab my
machine my my uh recording equipment and
at least shoot one play of this high
school game and i picked up the
equipment and the keys were right
underneath it
oh my god that's that's actually that's
a really good one that's such a rich
mistake see now the good thing for
snickers is i'm already going to the
super bowl so i'm not going to submit
because that would win
that would essentially win the entire
contest you would you would literally
end the contest
please
you just did
that's right you just announced it today
it's over
because i was a total rookie [ __ ] but
that's what you know you got you know
you're just not thinking straight pretty
much you know i needed snickers that's
what i'm saying at the time all right
hey before i let you go you you i'm sure
you're hearing what people are saying
about the steelers i'm sure you're
hearing that um
you know the way that you guys finished
last year
uh you're not the same pouncy's gone
a lot's happening and that people aren't
believing in you what do you say to
people who say that about the pittsburgh
steelers 2021 juju smith-schuster
oh man if you
just keep doubting us and we're going to
prove you guys on and let the past and
helmet speak for itself let the pads and
the helmets speak for themselves okay
because i'm sure you're hearing that
right i mean you're you're out there
you're on twitter you see all the stuff
that people are saying i see right i
assume or no
you
i mean i don't look at that kind of
stuff man uh just i know i'm on social
media a lot but yeah i'm not in that way
people are always gonna talk um y'all's
gonna have doubters and
uh
in that sense but
it's just part of life okay and then the
number of people that are picking the
team that you're playing this week to go
to the super bowl for the afc so already
you could basically stake your claim
week one against the buffalo bills
period right yep okay yes
all right i'll take that as a guarantee
okay can you write that down chris i'm
taking that as a guarantee from judaism
yeah that's another rookie mistake his
fifth year thanks for the call juju i
really appreciate it
thank you i appreciate it have a nice
day take care of yourself that's juju
smith shuster
on behalf of the snickers rookie mistake
of the year contest and pittsburgh
steelers right here on the rich eisen
show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here